I want to go
now to the former
assistant special Watergate prosecutor
who turned down a chance
to represent Donald Trump in the Mar
a Lago documents case.
John Sale,
I appreciate your time
and welcome to the show.
So I know that you know
Robert Costello, right.
So I gave a quick headline of him. Right.
He has represented
people like Steve Bannon, Rudy Giuliani.
Some people will make judgments
about that as they will.
What can you tell us about him?
What kind of a lawyer
he is, his character?
Well, I think we have to be careful
about equating a lawyer with his clients.
Whether that's a good thing
or a bad thing.
So I will.
Robert Costello, for starters, the former
assistant U.S.
attorney
in the Southern District of New York,
where I am also an alumni of that office.
He has an excellent reputation.
He did as a prosecutor.
He does as a defense lawyer,
is honorable.
He's a good lawyer.
And I have no doubt zero that he would
say double negative.
He would not lie under oath.
All right.
Well, and
so whatever he brings to the table,
I don't think he has an agenda
other than to tell the truth.
All right.
This is significant
because obviously a lot
could be resting on him.
And, you know,
he did come out
after his 3 hours in front of the grand
jury and spoke to the press.
He said he was frustrated
with the experience
because he said
that he had wanted
to talk about 300 emails
that he had exchanged with Michael Cohen
that he thought were very important.
But he said prosecutors
did not want to talk about that.
But they were way more narrow.
And here's what he said about it.
They were getting upset
because they asked me a limited question
based on one of these six emails,
and I would volunteer information
that I thought the grand
jury needed to hear.
So, John, what does this say to you?
He would volunteer information
to the grand jury needed to hear,
but they would only ask about six emails
when he had 300
he thought were important.
Well, where I start is that no
one is above the law,
including Donald Trump.
But that has to be viewed
in a spectrum of
we don't want to be involved
in selective prosecution.
We don't want to be
prosecuting Donald Trump for a matter.
We wouldn't prosecute
someone else for the
I don't know why the prosecutor doesn't
just let it all come out
before the grand jury
and let them decide.
A target of an investigation such as Mr.
Trump has a right to have the grand
jury hear exculpatory evidence
and then let them be an independent body,
weigh it all and and vote and apply
the law equally to him
the way they would to anybody else.
So let me say that
if you're going to compare
the credibility of Michael Cohen
and Bob Costello,
I mean,
that's not even worth a discussion.
But, you know,
Michael Cohen
is a defense lawyers dream as a witness.
I mean, a
first year law student could destroy him
on cross-examination.
And there was not a camera
he doesn't love.
He's on every TV show in the world.
And I don't criticize the media
or the public for wanting to hear it.
But when I was a prosecutor
or if I had a cooperator
and they wanted every TV show,
I would pull that cooperation deal.
So let me just ask you the bottom line.
As you see it, Ben,
do you think there's any chance
that Alvin Bragg does
not indict Donald Trump at this point?
I do think there is a chance
if a prosecutor does
a thorough investigation
and decides
not to prosecute,
he has not failed in his obligation.
And I think Bob Costello's testimony,
if nothing else, should cause Mr.
Bragg to at least pause
and think if this is the right case,
if there is the facts and the law,
Donald Trump should be held accountable.
But frankly,
I don't think this is the case.
And I think beyond a reasonable doubt
that Bob Costello
testimony tips
the scale in favor
of not bringing this case.
All right, John, thank you very much.
I appreciate your time
and the context that you bring to this,
which is so important.
OUTFRONT now, Ryan
Goodman, Karen Magnifico,
Basil SMIKLE and Scott Jennings.
Thanks very much to all of you.
So, Karen,
you worked in the Manhattan DA's office,
so you're very familiar
with all of this, right?
You know, obviously,
you were there
when there was a decision
not to go ahead and indict
on other issues related to Donald Trump.
How much do you think
Costello could impact the decision
on whether or not to indict Trump?
I think at this point
that Alvin Bragg
will likely ask the grand jury to decide.
Right.
They've heard all the evidence
and they've also heard COSTELLO. Right.
He was there for over three
or almost 3 hours today.
So to say that
there was any selective
questioning of him,
he had almost 3 hours to say
whatever it is that he wanted to say.
The grand
jury will have heard his testimony.
And I think at this point, Alvin
Bragg will likely
leave it up to the grand jury to decide
if they believe that
this case beyond a reasonable doubt.
That's not the standard
in the grand jury, by the way.
The standard in the grand
jury is probable cause. Right.
But I am sure simple majority. Right.
So it's exactly like an indictment.
You get one pretty much.
But, you know,
sometimes when
the defense presents evidence,
whether it's the defendant
testifying or other evidence
that's exculpatory and again,
almost 3 hours,
that's a long time to say
whatever it is he had to say.
And I think that that
that could influence a grand jury here.
So we'll see.
But I don't think that Alvin Bragg
will not ask the grand jury
to vote on this matter at this point.
Okay.
And Ryan,
so Michael Cohen
was not asked to testify.
He was there to be prepared for rebuttal,
Costello testified.
And then they said they did not need
Michael Cohen,
which we'll see if that's significant.
But then Cohen
obviously went out
and gave a television review,
and here's what he said.
Typical Donald J.
Trump play out of the playbook.
Figure out how you're going to muddy
the water as best as you possibly can.
Denigrate the person, disparage them.
They did the same thing to Cassidy
Hutchinson.
They did the same thing
to anyone and everyone that is it
is for the truth.
So he goes on to say,
The beauty is that I have facts.
Okay.
Now you
obviously hear what John Sayles says
about Costello
and his unimpeachable integrity
and the way, you know, his reputation.
But but what does this come down to then
for for a grand jury?
So I think in part, it might come down to
Cohen testifying.
But then what is there to corroborate
what he has to say?
Prosecutors often
have to include accomplices to the crime
or some bad actors,
especially when they're prosecuting,
for example, organized crime.
So you're going to have
some prosecutors, witnesses like that,
who have flipped and are cooperating
that aren't
the most appealing characters
and have done things like lie in the past
and commit past crimes.
But you need to
then go through
and corroborate everything.
So there is corroboration
in the case in the form of checks
that are written
by Donald Trump,
an audio
recording with Donald Trump
and Michael Cohen
and other witnesses
that can testify as well,
because part of this involved
the National Enquirer
as part of the hush money payment scheme,
and they have even a public document
with the federal prosecutors
that explains their role in the scheme
and that it was done
to influence the election.
So there's a lot of corroboration.
It's a question
of whether that can be put together
in such a way
that it would convince a jury.
And that is an open question,
and that is the open question,
because you also have, of course,
you know, a D.A.
here. Right? It's an elected position.
There's a lot at stake. Right.
You want reelection?
You know,
I would assume DA's
let's just assume
they always want to do the right thing.
But, you know, there's it's
there's pressure
after everything that the
D.A., Alvin Bragg, has gone through here,
is there an off ramp for him
if he wants one?
I mean, you heard Karen say he's
going to go ahead
and hand this to the grand jury.
Is there an off ramp if he wants one?
He is in an incredibly
difficult position.
You know, here's a guy who and I know him
voted for him.
If you look at his background,
he has represented white collar
while he's been involved
in white collar crimes
or fraud investigations.
He was worked at the U.S.
attorney's office.
So he sort of understands how that works.
And despite what may happen in New York
or maybe even counterintuitive
to being an elected official in New York,
he's going to
try to stay out of the papers
and off of TV
because he wants to be very careful.
On the other hand,
he campaigned
as a criminal justice reform
and as such,
he has been pilloried from the right,
particularly Donald Trump.
Lee Zeldin,
who ran for governor, ran
on taking him out of office
if he had won.
So he's an incredibly difficult position
because if he chooses, not if there is no
indictment here,
Donald Trump
can say, look, my protest,
my supporters got out there,
they pushed him back.
And they're going to be questions
about whether or not
he was up to the task.
On the other hand,
if there is an indictment,
Donald Trump
is going to come out and say,
look at this Democratic zealot
going after going, going after us.
He won't even say me.
He'll say us. Right.
So it's
a tough position for him to be in.
But I have to think that he
has enough experience
and support to at least be
I want to say hold back,
but at least be a lot more careful
than maybe one would think.
He's the former
president of the United States.
Tough call.
You know,
you said something in your answer that
that caught my attention.
You said if he doesn't indict,
people will say he wasn't up to the task.
What task?
What's the task?
Is the task
to get Donald Trump at all costs
or is the task
to do
what's right or to just execute the laws?
And I think that's where Republicans
have legitimate questions
about this
prosecutor, is he's thinking about
his political constituency.
Who would say what you just said?
If you don't get him,
you weren't up to the task
or is he actually thinking about the law?
You know, as prosecutor,
he has downgraded something
like 52% of felonies
down to misdemeanors.
In this case, he's taken a seven year
old paperwork misdemeanor
and inflating it to a convoluted novel
felony.
And I think a lot of Republicans
are looking at him saying,
thinking,
is he more political
than justice minded here?
Because of where he represents
in the voters that he has?
Since you asked.
I would say for the last several years,
through two impeachment
hearings, through a January six hearing,
there's a constant
push to hold him accountable.
So the question is,
is this holding him accountable?
If if the facts say that
we need to move on
and then look at something else?
I get that
I think most both voters would get that.
But there is going to also
be this question of
is there going to ever
come a point in time
when Donald Trump
will be held accountable
for the things that he's.
Well, I would think
I mean,
I would think the people in Georgia
and the special counsel at DOJ
have more legitimate things to care about
than perhaps.
And it's interesting
it will be interesting
to know
what they think about this
and whether, you know,
if they also were taken aback,
as everyone
was, frankly,
by the fact that this appears
to be coming first before anything else.